bonjour à tous je me trouve actuellement
au sein du conseil communautaire à
quelques mètres seulement de l'hôtel
d'agglomération un lieu méconnu du grand
public et pourtant c'est ici que sont
régulièrement voté les grandes
orientations de saint quentin en
yvelines le 9 janvier dernier les
représentants des douze communes qui
composent désormais la communauté
d'agglomération se sont réunis pour
élire entre autres le président de
l'intercommunalité
alors qu'ils votaient pour quoi et
surtout quelle responsabilité incombe
aux élus communautaires
les réponses dans votre ski mag c'est
parti
et
cette fois c'est officiel la nouvelle
communauté d'agglomération compte douze
communes
fin janvier les élus se sont retrouvés
au vélodrome nationale pour présenter
leurs voeux à la population et surtout
faire le point sur les enjeux qui
attendent saint-quentin-en-yvelines
misons sur l'audace la créativité
l'intelligence c'est ainsi que nous
resterons fidèles à notre identité et à
nos valeurs
mais qui sont donc toutes ces personnes
sur scène
et comment se sont-elles retrouvées là
un petit retour en arrière s'impose
en mars 2014 se tenait les élections
municipales à voter les électeurs des
douze communes de l'agglomération
étaient invités à choisir une liste au
sein de laquelle figurait un maire ses
adjoints et des conseillers municipaux
mais vous l'aviez peut-être alors
remarquer certains avaient une double
casquette il se portait en effet
également candidat pour siéger au sein
du conseil communautaire de saint
quentin en yvelines
ces personnes sur scène ont donc été
élus par les habitants de
l'agglomération
le nombre d'élus par commune est défini
en fonction de leur poids démographique
par exemple coignières compte deux élus
pour cinq mille habitants et montigny le
bretonneux 11 pour 34 mille habitants au
total ce sont 75 élus qui se sont réunis
le 9 janvier dernier au terme d'un
premier vote à bulletin secret michel
laugier a été élu président de saint
quentin en yvelines
je déclare l'élection de michel logé à
la présidence de 50 ans en ancien
journaliste michel laugier arrive à
montigny le bretonneux au milieu des
années 80 il intègre le service
communication de la ville avant de
devenir le directeur de cabinet du maire
de l'époque nicolas à bout après un
crochet par le secteur privé dans le
domaine publicitaire
il revient à montigny où il est élu
maire en 2001 mais revenons à notre
séance d'installation du conseil
communautaire que se passe t'il une fois
que le président a été élu
eh bien il va proposer un certain nombre
de vice présidence en l'occurrence 11
alors que sont ces vice présidence il
s'agit de domaines de compétences jugées
prioritaires par les élus majoritaires
de l'agglomération
les responsables de ces domaines de
compétences sont élus par les membres du
conseil communautaire et vous allez voir
que les nouveaux vice-présidents de
saint quentin en yvelines ont des
parcours professionnel et politique pour
le moins variées ce qui est intéressant
dans toute collectivité dans la relation
politique et c'est justement qu'ils
aient plusieurs sensibilités qu'ils
soient représentés que personne n'a le
même parcours que personne même profil
que personne événements allaient même
métier
et justement c'est à être issus de tous
ces univers
il fait que la décision que prendra de
manière collégiale sera finalement celle
qui sera le plus adapté
le territoire pour garantir un
développement du territoire conforme aux
besoins des saint quentinois
les élus vont devoir rédiger ensemble un
projet et c'est joséphine coleman ce
berger maire de plaisir qui a été
désigné par le vote pour chapeauter la
rédaction de ce document
metteur en scène de théâtre pendant 25
ans joséphine coleman ce berger occupe
pour la première fois une fonction
politique en 2001 en tant qu'adjointe à
la culture de la mairie de plaisir elle
est ensuite élu maire en 2008 selon elle
une feuille de route précise ans le
devenir de saint-quentin hamon
lien et long terme devraient émerger
dans les 12 ou 18 mois qui viennent il
est important de prendre le temps
puisque vous savez il va falloir faire
de jaloux on va dire une enquête je
n'aime pas le mot ou dit ça ne me plaît
pas mais en tout cas une enquête sur ce
qui est actuellement ce que ce qu'est le
territoire qui a quand même 40 années
d'existence et donc il est bon de
peut-être faire un arrêt sur image pour
voir ce qu'il en est et ensuite aller de
l'avant pour pouvoir voir vers où on
peut aller avec des possibilités
concrètes pas uniquement des mots mais
des actions compétences essentielles de
saint quentin en yvelines le
développement économique et
l'enseignement supérieur sont confiés au
maire d'elancourt jean michel fourgous
arrivé il ya une vingtaine d'années à
saint quentin en yvelines
cet ancien chercheur et chefs
d'entreprise et notamment passionné par
les technologies numériques en tant que
deuxième vice président il souhaite
faire bénéficier les saint quentinois de
son expérience il voit la communauté
d'agglomération comme un
démultiplicateur de talent ou
enseignement supérieur et
entrepreneuriat sont intimement liés au
coeur d'un même territoire
les jeunes pousses comme il les appelle
peuvent étudier faire de la recherche
mais également développer leurs
activités économiques en bénéficiant
d'un véritable accompagnement un
incubateur que l'on va créer et au bout
de deux ans on le passe à promo paul ou
là effectivement c'est une autre étape
où là il va bien sûr parfaire son réseau
commercial il ya comme ça voire ses
premiers clients recevoir à faire ses
premières prestations et puis après
troisième étape
on y trouve des locaux à l'intérieur
d'une des douze communes de saint
quentin en yvelines et bien entendu avec
une série de services on l'être bien sûr
à se financer
parce que c'est un métier on l'aide à
choisir des talents et puis bien sûr
être un démultiplicateur de contact de
prospects il faut l'aider à échanger
très vite elle trouver très vite des
clients avoir des rencontres rentrer
dans des réseaux d'entrepreneurs
véronique côté millard et la nouvelle
vice présidente en charge de la mobilité
et des transports
après des études de commerce elle
démarre une carrière dans l'export avant
d'ouvrir son affaire puis de partir un
temps aux états unis
installée aux clayes-sous-bois depuis
une trentaine d'années elle en est la
maire depuis 2001 pour elle la question
des transports est essentiel car son
transport pas d'emploi alors oui il y a
le projet de la ligne 18 mais pas
seulement au niveau de
l'intercommunalité elle-même je pense
qu'il ya également des enjeux puisque
c'est une ville nouvelle
d'après ce que j'ai regardé au moins
pour relier les territoires entre eux
puisque eeel et les interconnexions se
font surtout par véhicule véhicule
personnel
on a également les enjeux donc c'est
effectivement de avec la région d'avoir
plus de train d'avoir plus de
déplacements parle par mu et pour les
communes en 30 nous on est pratiquement
à l'âge de pierre au niveau des
transports donc on espère pouvoir
s'inscrire dans cette nouvelle dynamique
est justement pouvoir profiter de
l'existence
grégory gare et astier est à présent à
la tête de la gestion de la mutation
urbaine et de la stratégie commerciale
mort passe bien depuis toujours il est
titulaire d'un master de sciences
politiques spécialité communication
une fois son diplôme en poche il devient
fonctionnaire territorial et intègre le
service communication d'une collectivité
locale
sa vice présidence se compose de deux
grands axes qu'il considère comme
complémentaires pour ce qui est de la
rénovation urbaine
l'un des enjeux principaux et l'anru 2
qui devrait favoriser la mixité sociale
et pour la stratégie commerciale
l'objectif est de développer une sorte
de complémentarité intercommunale je
crois qu'il faut qu'on ait une cohérence
maintenant sur l'ensemble du territoire
et non plus que l'on soit en concurrence
effrénée
c'est une délégation sur mesure qui
n'existait pas jusqu'à présent je me
suis inspiré de mon vécu avec
l'expérience que j'ai sur la zone
d'activités paris ouest qui est à cheval
sur nos repas et coignet en tout pendant
des années des deux villes est en
concurrence et donc puisque maintenant
nous sommes dans l'année
l'agglomération douze communes il faut
que tout ça s'articule avec une
complémentarité et donc il ya un grand
travail à faire et c'est tout l'objectif
de ma délégation
aménagement du territoire et habitat
deux compétences cher au coeurs
d'alexandra rosetti cet ancien
professeur d'anglais arrivée à saint
quentin en yvelines en 93 a enseigné
pendant plus de 20 ans en collège et
lycée à trappes et montigny depuis 2014
elle est mère de voisins-le-bretonneux
en substance elle explique que pour sa
partie l'enjeu pour saint quentin en
yvelines et de construire du logement
tout en amenant plus d'homogénéité sur
le territoire
la construction elle a déjà commencé il
ya pas mal de projets on vient de revoir
notre plan local d'urbanisme vient de le
rendre intercommunale donc ça a permis à
chaque commune du coup de retravailler
son plan local d'urbanisme de se
repositionner
voilà l'enjeu c'est ça c'est que il faut
peut-être revenir un petit peu sur la
façon dont ça s'est fait dans le passé
pourrait dans le passé en fait on avait
un peu vu saint quentin en yvelines avec
différents quartiers on va dire à leurs
voisins c'est un peu le quartier
résidentiel
et puis d'autres villes étaient plus se
tourner vers le logement social d'autres
villes plus vers les entreprises et donc
là aujourd'hui
il s'agit de rééquilibrer tout ça mais
de façon la plus harmonieuse possible la
difficile question du budget est
désormais gérée par stéphane mirambeau
maire de villepreux attiré par le cadre
de vie ils arrivent sur le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines en 1997 il est
titulaire de l'équivalent d'un master 2
en informatique et travaille dans une
société de conseil
d'après lui pour préparer les
investissements de demain il va falloir
tenir compte du désengagement de l'état
regardez toutes les lignes inspectez
épluché analysés par allez je vais
rencontrer les différents services voir
ce qu'il est possible de faire et bien
sûr dans la concertation avec les
différents maires de saint quentin
l'objectif c'est que c'est que de
trouver un
consensus de trouver des marges de
manoeuvre de ne pas passer en force bien
sûr et faire le plus de propositions
possibles
je pense que nous avons tous le même
objectif renforcer le socle financier de
cette interco pour pouvoir justement
trouver les marges de manoeuvre pour
préparer l'avenir et le développement
économique et la création de richesses
pour le sport il fallait un sportif
jean-pierre sevestre est le nouveau vice
président en charge de cette compétence
au combien importante à saint quentin en
yvelines
ce passionné de cyclisme arrive à
coignières en 1974 après des études de
commerce et une carrière d'une
quarantaine d'années dans le secteur
bancaire il s'engage en politique
pour lui le sport apporte un lien social
intergénérationnel entre des populations
venues de tous horizons
durant sa vice présidence il aura
notamment à gérer des dossiers en lien
avec de grands événements sportifs
l'alstom open
de golf également la ryder cup pour 2018
et puis il ya également
la préparation des jeux olympiques 2024
ce sont les grands événements dans une
vice présidence chargée des sports je
pense que c'est important mais il est
important également
lorsque l'intérêt communautaire
effectivement sera bien défini importer
la différentes aides aux différents
clubs de l'intercommunalité moderniser
l'administration et évaluer les
politiques publiques sont les missions
d'armelle aubry y est diplômé de
polytechnique
elle arrive à saint quentin en yvelines
en 1983 elle fait toute sa carrière dans
l'informatique le contrôle de gestion et
la gestion d'entreprise
sa tâche s'annonce ardue notamment à
cause de la baisse de la dotation
globale de fonctionnement
il est clair qu'il faut qu'on trouve 15
millions d'euros en trois ans et que
donc on étudie très sérieusement tout ce
qui correspond à nos compétences
la façon dont on les utilise et ce
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait effectivement
amélioré arrêté un des problèmes du
millefeuille français c'est que chacun
il ne risque pas strictement danser dans
ses compétences mais pour peut-être des
problèmes politiques ou des choses comme
ça essaye de faire un petit peu ce que
feraient les shows dessus ce que
prennent les gens en dessous la voirie
l'éclairage public et la sécurité ont
été confiés à bernard meyer cet
entrepreneur aujourd'hui retraité est
arrivé à plaisir en 1978 les compétences
dont il a la charge
nécessiteront incontestablement une
mutualisation de moyens côté sécurité
l'élu doit rencontrer tous les acteurs
du territoire afin d'élaborer un plan
qui comporte notamment le développement
de vidéosurveillance et côté voirie
l'objectif est déjà bien défini
avoir un maillage cohérent au niveau de
la du développement futur de l'ensemble
de l'agglomération à travers les
circulations douces à travers le plan de
développement cohérent de l'améliorer de
le développer concernant les
circulations pour les transports en
commun et bien évidemment sans oublier
tout ce qui concerne les
véhicule non polluant gerald de favier
le nouveau vice président en charge de
la communication et des grands
événements élan courtois depuis 1970 il
commence sa carrière en tant
qu'ingénieur puis commerciale et enfin
chef d'entreprise il affiche une
ambition sans borne pour saint quentin
en yvelines qu'il souhaite voir rayonner
au delà de ses frontières
cela passe notamment par une nouvelle
identité visuelle qui fait la part belle
aux initiales de l'agglomération est-ce
qu y
nous avons voulu surtout conserver
s'implanter en hybride car depuis 40 ans
tout ce qui se fait au niveau de ce
territoire
à la base c'est 51 10 vies et nous ne
souhaitions pas nous trouver une autre
appellation que ce nom qui doit rayonner
au firmament je dirais donc de la l'île
de france mais également au niveau
national et international
et c'est ce qui a prévalu dans le choix
qui a été fait je crois avec
l'assentiment de tous les élus
jean-pierre plus haut s'est vu confier
la charge du patrimoine bâti
communautaire des espaces verts et
aquatiques et du développement durable
ses 44 ans de carrière se sont déroulés
dans le bâtiment et la fonction publique
engagé politiquement depuis la fin des
années 70 il a par ailleurs été
formateur et secouriste de la croix
rouge française
saint quentin en yvelines est souvent
qualifiée de territoire vert et bleu et
tout l'enjeu de cette vice-présidence
est que cela continue pour le futur et
répondent
mon problème du réchauffement climatique
dans les prochaines années c'est
l'isolation des bâtiments la
préservation tous les milieux naturels
que nous avons et l'entretien de façon
écologique ne vous êtes pas de vert et
de nous
vous êtes mal choisi voilà j'espère vous
en avoir appris un peu plus sur ce que
vous avez élu à la tête de saint quentin
en yvelines ski mag revient très vite
pour un prochain numéro
d'ici là portez vous bien ciao bye